I wanted to recreate a character
reminiscent of what forbidden siren did
with their character so created a low
poly character model once we had this we
then took photographs of two different
facial expressions and used these
pictures to create a texture using the
UV unwrapping of the head from that low
poly 3D model to create the facial
expressions I needed to create a Sprite
sheet and once I have my Sprite sheet I
can then put that into unroll engine and
use that in my material that IID already
set up with a flip book however I
realize I wasn't getting the small cross
fade that I noticed when looking at
forbidden Sirens characters but what I
did in the end was actually just set up
two flip books of the same Sprite sheet
and have the output material just output
a blend of both of these flip books and
then just have one start slightly
earlier than the other